foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth
do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for hanging out
with us America we're so glad you're
here my co-host today Ramsey personality
Jade warshaw and for this segment we
invited Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book own your past change
your future and apparently getting ready
to be a number one best-selling author
on this new one called building a
non-anxious life uh we put this thing up
for sale in pre-sale yesterday and it is
breaking records thank you guys we
appreciate your response to it
apparently there's a lot of people that
need to build an unanxious life or they
know someone that does and so thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
we appreciate your response the book is
twenty dollars and we give you seventy
five dollars worth of goodies to
pre-purchase it the book will actually
be shipped to you on Pub date October
3rd along with the audiobook the e-book
and right now as soon as you buy it
we're going to send you a copy of John's
uh one of his talks as well which is a
really good talk and so this whole
subject of
anxiety misunderstood in it John yeah we
we've got a whole culture designed to
help people not feel anxious anymore and
I think we've gone about that all the
wrong way I think anxiety is our body
trying to get our attention and say hey
we're not okay on on multiple areas
we're not okay and if you just climb up
in your in your kitchen man and you pull
the batteries out of the smoke alarm
you've stopped the noise man but your
house is going to burn down around you
yeah I mean I you should feel anxious if
crap is going bad absolutely if you're
standing in the interstate and an
18-wheeler is coming at you you should
be anxious exactly if you owe a bunch of
money if you're at a place where you're
not safe if you're an abusive
relationship if
um you haven't slept in four days and
you live off Red Bull and and taking
pills to get rid of your anxiety doesn't
solve the problem it does turn the
alarms down doesn't solve the problem
right and so we just simply have to have
a conversation
um across the country about
reimagining the way we do our lives and
hey by the way this is a conversation
I've been having for several years with
my friends who are medical practitioners
who are therapists psychologists
everybody knows we know that it's kind
of in this Log Jam and it just takes
some people to have some have the
conversation we're living the most
anxious all the data says the most
anxious culture in history it's wild man
it's wild and the wealthiest yeah and
the there's all these reasons it
shouldn't be but it is we have no
saber-toothed tigers tigers I'm 100 I
have data to prove that yeah there are
no saber-toothed tigers chasing us so we
don't have to be anxious but we have 10
o'clock texts from our bosses saying
where's the budget and we have emails
and we have mother-in-laws and our
bodies just can't handle it all man so
what you're saying it's not just a DNA
genetic thing absolutely not yeah yeah
absolutely not that's one of the big
ones is hey this is just the way you are
right sorry
um you have a disease yeah you were you
were born broken you're not your body's
not right
um almost there's some rare medical
exceptions but almost always no some
people are more sensitive like to the
world I am my wife is not right I can
say hey I think we're gonna die and
she's like we're fine John right so my
my alarms are tuned a little more finely
than hers
um but no I'm not broken in any way yeah
and there's six daily choices that you
can engage in which will address the
real problems the the real fire that's
causing the smoke alarm to go off the
problem is causing the anxiety to come
up and if you address those six daily
choices
that's how you build an onxtrous life
yeah and I think that what you said is
important though well and some of them
some of them are going to be easy for
people like for my wife budgeting and
paying off debt okay that just makes
sense for me a budget felt like I was
getting dragged behind a boat right
um for other people like going to
counseling that wasn't hard for me like
I'm happy to do that some people will
fight that tooth and nail and so
everybody has different challenges
Something's Gonna be easier some of
these are going to be harder but I've
heard it said this way and this isn't
definitely I didn't make this up but if
you want to begin to heal your mental
health and you want to begin to change
your emotional health it's like brushing
your teeth we don't want to get cavities
and so we brush our teeth in the morning
we brush our teeth in the evening and so
really this book is laying it out as
simple as brushing your teeth here are
some things you can do every day here's
some things you can do every week every
month that are going to create a culture
where you might get the occasional
cavity and by the way
this book does not insulate you from bad
things happening your mom's going to get
sick you're going to get a kid that um
gets bullied at school you're going to
lose your job that's life but this book
is about giving you the margin and
capacity to take life when it hits you
in the mouth and the life we live now
Dave we're so spun up and burned out and
anxious and fried and then when life
does what life does we're out we have no
capacity he just knocks you out of the
saddle that's right yeah but this will
fill you you get your tank full then
stuff comes at you you got a full tank
to deal with it yep yeah sure it's your
only shot so good stuff building a
non-anxious life uh Ramsay publishing's
latest number one bestseller I'm sure
not yet officially but we won't know
till October but by the way you guys
speaking of that can help us by
pre-purchasing the book it'll help John
help us we appreciate it so if you want
to be a supporter of what we're doing
that one way you do it is simply buy the
book early we're going to bribe you to
do it the book's 20 bucks and we're
going to give you 75 worth of goodies to
buy it early and because all the sales
we made make before Pub day count on Pub
date towards the best seller list so
legally technically we've got it all
worked out at no nobody's scamming
anybody we're my scam in the list we're
just trying to sell a bunch of books and
help a bunch of people pretty simple or
a bunch of people sell a bunch of books
however that works and so jump on at
ramseysolutions.com the book is called
building a non-anxious life Dr John
deloney's latest we did Issue a quick
read back last year which is a chapter
book basically 37 pages about read
called redefining anxiety that sold 150
000 copies of this tiny little pamphlet
book and proving that this subject
matters yeah and it was my buddies who
were
psychologists and counselors who are in
in medical doctors who are buying it by
the case and just giving it to their
their clients and their patients saying
hey this is as simple as we can get it
to you we can help you out with this and
I think that's another important thing
I spent 20 years in higher education I
spent 20 years with some of the greatest
loving wonderful scientists great
thinkers great people and this book
isn't written for them this book is
written for folks who are who don't read
a lot of books who are just trying to it
was just what I got two two kids and I
just want a little more piece in my home
I'm an over the road truck driver and I
just want to be a better dad and I don't
even know where to start
um this is the exhausted 50 year old mom
who has to do something different this
is the 61 year old dad who's just like
hey I want to re-engage with my kids
after a lifetime and kind of being
separate this is a book for people who
don't read books this is I try to make
it as simple as possible and it's direct
and clean and clear as possible the goal
here is not to sound smart the goal here
is to help people live a better life
well look I'm a person who's not ever
considered myself an anxious person and
I read redefining anxiety I read own
your past change your future I can't
wait to read this book because I think
even if you're not a person who would
say I'm anxious or there's so many dated
day things that take place in our life
that affect us and you can just keep
your head down and just keep going
through acting like it's not having an
effect on you and it is and even if you
don't consider yourself uh labeled in
that way there's still so much in this
book that is going to be able to help
you I appreciate that yeah
congratulations on another success Dr
John thank you much for your support
grateful Dr John deloney the book is
building a non-anxious life
ramsaysolutions.com click on the store
get you one this
here's the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
Carlos is with us in San Antonio Texas
hi Carlos how are you
hi how you doing thanks for having me
sure what's up
well
um I live abroad I live and work abroad
I'm finally back in the U.S after about
four years I was stuck because of covid
um so about a year and a half ago I sold
my house while I was abroad and I wanted
to now finally use the money and invest
and make it work for me
um now I've been back in the US for
about two years I have a meeting with a
friend who's a banker and we're going to
talk about possible Investments but um I
have a friend who bought a piece of uh
property in Thailand for about 30 30 000
in cash and I was thinking about doing
the same thing so I might actually be in
Thailand in about the next three weeks
or so to take a look at some things
um it's just the first time I've had a
quite a chunk of change in the bank with
uh and being debt free so I was looking
to do something with that
what is the size of the chunk of change
[Music]
290 000. okay and what do you make a
year
uh
uh I would say about 80
000 but I pretty much live uh for free
not not for free but it's fair the cost
of living is very low I gotcha yeah
um
I would not buy that
okay and I'll tell you why
because there's a bazillion
thirty thousand dollar Investments to do
in the United States and
um the Thai economy is excellent uh it
is a fairly stable situation but there
is not any
um
any close to any country in the world
that is as stable and predictable in
environment as the United States
and when I buy Investments I want stable
and predictable
and the thing that we forget As
Americans is is that uh you know ever so
often some of these countries just blow
up and I'm not predicting Thailand's
going to blow up that is not what I said
okay but we're just not used to the uh
volatility of government the volatility
of things
um and for you have to have a
predictable environment for economics to
work that's why Law and Order order
versus the opposite of order is chaos
and so when you have chaos you do not
have a predictable environment and
business and Merchants and transactions
cannot occur predictably that's why the
inner city in some of these wonderful
American cities have just been destroyed
because they've lost the uh they've lost
order they've turned to chaos and that's
a miniature version of it happening to
an entire country so uh I I would
instead have my money Stateside uh than
doing your very first investment in 10
percent event or twenty percent of your
whole net worth is going to be in a less
predictable environment that's a kind
easy way of saying it so you can do it
if you want to but I wouldn't that's my
reasoning I wouldn't do it not no you
and I have both traveled all over the
world yes and it's easy to
when you're when you're traveling it's
also easy as an American to say okay
everywhere operates the same way and it
doesn't no it doesn't and you kind of
get enamored with these places it's like
oh this would be so nice and you're
seeing beautiful it's beautiful exactly
I I just think that with real estate
especially it sounds like he's a guy
that hops around he likes to travel it
just feels like
not the move I'm with you I would invest
Stateside it's an environment that you
probably know a little bit more about
not to mention his buddy the banker gave
him the advice which no he was meeting
with him later about meeting with the
baker okay because I was like I don't
know if I let my banker tell me that I'm
not gonna say my buddy my banker tell me
anything about Investments okay Bankers
or where you deposit money not where you
go for investment advice that's right so
uh anyway so that's the second part of
the equation you didn't ask Carlos but I
would go to an actual
professional broker that gives people
advice not a banker there's a difference
there's a substantial difference the way
their brains work so yeah if you want to
find out who we recommend for that just
click on Smart investor at Ramsay
Solutions and you'll find someone that
is a professional that knows what
they're doing that
um that it does investing for a living
and works with giving advice for a
living and that kind and that's who I
that's who I have in my corner and Jade
has in her corner so but uh so that's
the second part of unsolicited advice
here so well he was on the right track
wanting to pay cash well you know that
that yeah he is and that does Parlay I
mean I'll continue that conversation
um
the uh I was thinking about this other
day one of my buddies is all talked out
about all the Anarchy stuff and all the
the protests and people burning stuff
down he was just he's going nuts his
brain's you know he's all he's all
he's spending way too much of his
calories on it because he hadn't got
anything to do with him really but but I
was trying to explain to him it's it's
not the um I mean the weird thing about
Anarchy is
if it works you burn everything to the
ground and there's nothing left
that's the purpose of Anarchy is chaos
to destroy every known existing
institution okay and so when you do that
100 of the time what happens after that
another group of Institutions rise up
and they start ruling and the anarchists
are now in charge of that which is the
actual Paradox of Anarchy yeah so I mean
and the problem with all that idea is
that in the process of doing that you
destroy you know what's happening on a
miniature level as I said where you do
not have a predictable environment of
order versus chaos you cannot do
business so in other words let's just
put it into basic terms uh Little Couple
has saved up money they got forty
thousand bucks and they want to open an
ice cream shop okay they are not if they
have wisdom going to open an ice cream
shop in an area that regularly kicks in
the windows and steals everything
because they're putting their stuff at
risk right and so if you want to make
sure that your area has absolutely no
business investment which leads to
Prosperity because it leads to
employment
if you want to make sure your area has
that then just remove order and insert
chaos because you will guarantee the
failure of prosperity in the area
because it's a natural thing for you
people to say I'm not going to open my
ice cream shop where people are going to
burn it absolutely I mean it's silly you
know and and some of these cities the
inner cities are not coming back after
these riots they're just sitting down
there boarded up and that's why because
people lost the belief that there was
order instead they have a belief that
there's chaos so when someone says Law
and Order sometimes people think oh well
that means the police are just kicking
people and hitting people and that isn't
what it means at all Law and Order means
that there's a law
an order is kept as opposed to chaos and
that's not a a racial decision that's
not a defund the police decision it's
none of those things at all it's simple
that you cannot have economic prosperity
in areas where you do not have a
predictable environment and so you've
got to and the same thing happens in
your personal life you have to create a
predictable environment so if all you
and your wife your husband do is fight
all the time
very seldom are you going to prosper
because you're in the middle of chaos
all the time and you don't have a
predictable environment so it's very
difficult to invest in believe in and
pour your life into something called a
future because all you're dealing is
you're burning all your calories dealing
with the toxic mess that is in your
house and so it can be in your house it
can be in your town it can be in your
country but order is essential to
prosperity and and that that's what I
was trying to explain to my buddy who's
drunk the Kool-Aid of some right wing
crazy butt stuff but um you know it's a
very simple thing and it's not a mean
thing and it's not really even a moral
judgment it's not a uh uh you know what
do we do about it yeah what do you do
about but you got to have order
and if you don't have order then you're
not by definition ultimately going to
have Prosperity I hear what you're
saying Dave it has to be a predictable
environment and so that that's the thing
and Investments business Investments
where jobs come from uh you're not going
to have the low couples not gonna open
their ice cream store and that just
tells you what's happening and so that's
what's weird is if you burn your own
neighborhood down that's what you're
doing to yourself
it is not just your ear
it's just so illogical I don't get it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality joins me today Jay is in
Boise Idaho hi Jay welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave thank you so much this is
awesome to be on here I appreciate the
opportunity well thank you how can we
help
so just to give a little preface
um my company that I work for they're
awesome they uh we had an opportunities
at The Summit in April and so that's
kind of how I started to learn about you
guys and then they offered to buy
everyone spu if they want it of course I
jump on my wife and so we're in that
right now
and so anyway we're I think week two or
three right now
and um I guess my question is is
I we have a student loan debt a student
loan and a car loan that we're going to
completely pay off in January the car
loan but I also have a social impact
business on the side and so I'm trying
to figure out what like is there a way
to kill two birds with one stone and
what's the smartest way to do that like
to make sure that I'm paying off my debt
wisely but also not leaving the the my
business
um stagnant does that make sense yes
I do think okay so you've got a job that
you like and you've got this business on
the side right so what percentage of
your income your personal income is
coming from the job that you love and
what percentage of the income is coming
from your business
I would say 95 comes from my the job
that I love and then right five percent
comes it's it's and I kind of think it's
a little bit of a moot point right
because you've got this income here that
you can easily use towards going towards
your debt and the you know five percent
you know like reinvested in your
business or whatever keep it going but
it's not as though
you know that business is your soul
thing and you're trying to decide should
I take this money out to help my feed my
family or should I reinvest it you've
got the ability to kind of have that on
the side keep it going and then you've
got them the vast vast majority of your
income to throw towards your debt
snowball what do you make
so I was my current job I made close to
70 000 and I also I'm a freelancer on
the side with two clients that make me
another 10 000 a year and then I have
that business on the side which makes so
much
um
it's
let's see it's not profitable it's not
no it's it's profitable it's just a very
small amount of profit
um like a couple hundred bucks yeah like
I say a couple like last year we made
maybe three or four grand this year we
made Maybe
maybe two grand
so what it basically sorry to give you a
little Preface on that what it is is I
I sell Polynesian design shirts to the
number one paid tourist attraction in
Hawaii okay and with that money I pull
out like five to ten percent of that
profit but the rest of it I'm using it
to help Polynesians to
um achieve their dreams basically so
like whether that's through a
scholarship that's through
um home ownership things like that but
right now obviously it's so small I've
only been able to endorse two or three
people yeah
um with their Endeavors
um just leave that thing alone
let it run itself don't add to it don't
take anything out of it
okay and then go then go work your stuff
now how much is your car debt and your
student loan debt so my car Dad is
um
it is ten thousand
um and my my wife's student loan debt is
uh around thirty two thousand
um and in January well we're gonna we're
paying our car off enough to where I
think by January we should have it down
to maybe 8 500 and there's an incentive
bonus that I'm planning on getting from
the company that'll wipe that out that
car loan out
that's what I plan to use that you need
to pay off more than fifteen hundred
dollars worth of debt in six months
okay I'm gonna gear this up that's gonna
take forever
okay so you guys need to lean in let's
get this let's get a whole bunch of
stuff it'd be really fun if you could
like have the car paid off by January
really yeah and then throw the 8 500 at
the student loan or something like that
I want to gear this up and that may be
gearing up the freelance it's certainly
going to be gearing down some of your
spending definitely and uh I I really
want to lean into this and get this
stuff going because you got forty two
thousand dollars worth of debt you make
80. so if you want to be done in two
years you need to do 21 000 a year
that's almost two thousand dollars a
month not two thousand dollars between
now and Christmas mm-hmm
yeah I think I could do it too no I know
you can do it we can do it you you can
do it Yep this is doable you you can get
there Jay and that that's that's how I
do that you just run your math out like
that and then it makes it believable and
once it's believable then the hustle's
worth it that's right the grind is worth
it the extra hours are worth it but you
got to believe it's going to something
it's not just a rat and a wheel anymore
right I got you got to feel the traction
you got to see the traction and when you
do that then you'll go do anything I
mean that's he and his wife he making an
additional thousand dollars a month
doing something
yeah you know what I'm saying that's how
much quickly how much more quickly they
can move yeah I double the freelance
yeah and just let the let the uh uh we
don't want the uh social impact to run
out sure but we also don't we're not
trying to put a bunch of calories into
it to run it up right now we're ready to
sit there and maintain and then when you
get this debt clear you're going to be
in a position to really lean into it and
make it go yeah that's right that's good
yeah very good Jay very cool hey thanks
for calling in man Stacy's with us in
Cleveland Ohio hi Stacy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thank you for having me sure what's
up
um I really appreciate your show
um I've only been a listener for a
couple weeks now and I'm obsessed with
you guys I think everything
you have to say is awesome and it
totally applies to everyday life but
thank you we appreciate that kind of
obsession
that's another one too far that's going
too far
we still love you
I do hear some single moms call in but
I'm one of those so and I appreciate
your podcast and all your information I
just I was hoping maybe that you could
give me some advice as a single parent
because
it's really hard to squeeze blood out of
the turnip you know yeah
I'm really trying I'm actually you know
looking into
um selling my house and I I've been here
for 14 years and I bought it for
you know very cheap and why are you
selling it
um
smaller
type
is
me oh gosh I'm almost 48. and how many
kids do you have
I have two two what are their ages
27 and 15. okay so you want something
smaller and accessible you're downsizing
preparation to be an empty nester
purchase a mobile home or building a
small house on that land no no mobile
homes they go down in value
um what about the land plan to be okay
but I'm confused is that are we doing a
house or are we doing land
well I'm kind of tired with this house
so I was thinking of land with a small
house like maybe building something
really small on that land oh I see okay
yeah
well there's nothing on fire here to do
this you can do it anytime the next
three or four years right
yes okay I mean 15 year old leaves home
it'd be nice to have it done
what would you take away from it
um at least 100 grand
okay
what do you make
I don't make much so I'm a nurse I do
home care I have my own home care
business I that's another thing I don't
make much so I'm kind of like that's why
I'm saying like drawing nothing is hard
why don't you make much doing nurse Home
Care
well I do I charge my own rates but it's
still
what is your income what do you pay
taxes on how much do you make
I make about 50 a year and I have to be
there for my son yeah he's older but I
have to be there because you know he's
that age I I'm working why have you
chosen to make half what you can make
well that's part of the question I'm
asking what else can I do I'm kind of
stuck I guess I mean it might not be as
flexible or it might not be exactly what
you want to do but nurses can make 80 to
100K
and uh in Cleveland Ohio and so I'm
going to start thinking about I can go
make some money to make some of these
other dreams come true
um instead of uh
yeah you're under your incomes under
what your what you should be making for
your wonderful career field
and I think that would help you move
some things along this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
Ashley is in Denver hi Ashley welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
I really appreciate it sure what's up
uh my husband and I are are wanting to
sell one of our side businesses which is
a vending machine business and we are
wondering if we should hire a business
broker or what are our best options to
try and sell this business
how many machines have we got
about 30 locations 30 machines or a
little more
um what's it making 30 35 machines uh
this year we are estimated to make 90k
um last year it was like around 75 and
then
um the year before that was about 65 to
70.
um post pandemic but we profit about
somewhere between 60 to 65. cool okay
good all right
um you ever sold a business before
no okay okay
um well the a business broker a good one
would uh bring two or three things for
you one is they're going to help you put
an accurate value on it
two is uh they're gonna obviously have
some potential clients we hope that
they'll do bring to it and three is
they'll help you do the paperwork a part
of the transaction in a way that
protects you and the buyer uh if they're
a good business broker now I'm sorry
okay
there's the people
okay well you can do all of that uh
probably less expensive with a basic
attorney if you have an attorney that
you use for things that it's really not
a it's really not rocket science to
transfer of the assets and and verify
payment
um in escrow in order to do that that
that's really not that big a deal you
think you found you think you find the
buyer
um
no we don't have anybody we're hoping to
try it and sell this by the end of the
year but we're just kind of in a
um starting out stages of figuring out
what to do next what's made you kind of
I'm just curious what made you say I
want to I'm we're ready to sell this
business
um we think you can kind of run its
course it was it's been really great to
us um but we also have a couple other
side businesses plus my husband's
full-time job
um and it's just kind of
um it is very labor intensive and takes
a lot of our time
um so we just are kind of thinking it'd
be nice to kind of unload it basically
so you say you make a profit 60 that
doesn't count paying you labor
uh I mean it's just me and my husband so
so pay you labor basically
you're you're in other words the 60 is
after cost of goods sold but you didn't
pay any labor out of that
okay all right so the way you value a
business is you value it as a standalone
business not people working for free
okay and so you know by that I mean an
absentee investor
and so if I want to actually value it I
would say what would it and I want to
buy it I live in Tennessee and I wonder
I have somebody run it what would it
cost me to hire somebody to run it and
run the machines
probably 30 or 40 Grand right
okay is that probably right I don't know
how long how many hours a week does it
take to run it
um
probably I mean depending on how many
locations we have to do that week it
could only just about four or five well
I mean average
through throughout the month I'm sorry
uh probably about five hours a week okay
cool okay then it's not 30 or 40K
that's a hard time you have somebody as
a part-time If you hired a part-time
employee to do all the work
what would you pay them do you think
for five hours a week to go do this
stuff I mean if you paid them really
really good you pay them a couple
hundred bucks a week right
sure so like I'm sorry my husband's the
more well I mean okay I mean that would
be that would if you paid them twenty
dollars an hour that would be a hundred
dollars for five hours right
yes okay and if you doubled that paid
them forty dollars an hour make it the
best part-time job on the planet okay
right then you got 200 a week and so
eight hundred dollars a month is ten
thousand dollars a year okay so I'm
trying to figure out if I wanted to hire
somebody to do this if I could find
somebody trustworthy and pay them really
good per hour but then uh and then I I
trust them with the whole operation and
so let's call that ten thousand dollars
okay so if you made sixty and I pay
labor out of it now you got a fifty
thousand dollar net worth so you're our
fifty thousand dollar net profit so the
way we value most businesses and I'm not
used to valuing particularly vending
machine businesses but basically a
business is worth somewhere around four
to five times its net profit after all
real expenses are removed
so that means that this business is
worth somewhere around 200 to 250. does
that sound like anything y'all been
talking about
what you think it was worth
it we were thinking it was more or less
like 70 or 80k
oh really why where did you get that
um in like the vending or at least what
we had seen in the vending world that's
kind of what people have told us for
okay one times cash flow okay well that
might be it might be well what it's
worth I don't know
um and so uh but that so there we go
again do you want a business broker so
if you sell something for 70k what's the
business broker going to get 20
commission 15 commission whatever it is
that's you know is it worth
uh you know 15 10 15 000 bucks for uh
them to help you value this properly and
to do the paperwork and help you find a
buyer I'm
for you guys to sell
you don't want to do because you're the
you're in the position to profit and not
do the work you're just overseeing
somebody trustworthy who you're going to
pay ten thousand dollars a year
that's kind of the problem we're not
quite sure who we could even figure out
to hire there's a lot of cash involved
um and things like that
um we don't do just strictly credit
cards so it would be so you're going to
the machines picking up getting all the
cash you've got all the coins and
everything
well okay I I'm going to I I told you up
front I don't know how to value a
vending machine business I'm valuing a
business in general so I want you to do
some more research
um rather than I just heard from some
guy who sold a machine once uh I really
want to find out what the standard is in
that industry if it is only one-time
cash flow that's not much if it's one
time cash flow I'm keeping it and I'm
hiring somebody yeah absolutely but the
uh uh but if you can get two times or
three times in the and the going rate is
two times but that see it let's pretend
you accepted 60 000 bucks for this
business and it was actually worth 120
or 200. well they're a business broker
would have paid for themselves helping
you properly value it so call some
business brokers to have some
conversations
and find out what it is they're going to
get that makes them worth what you are
paying them
and that's what it amounts to uh if you
want to value your own business then you
would search among
friends in other cities other people in
the vending world and try to learn what
it's actually worth I truly don't know
I've worked with a lot of different
things with vending a lot of different
small businesses over the years we work
with tens of thousands of small
businesses and entree leadership but
that's a standard valuation method it's
called a cap rate method that I was
using a capitalization rate and so
um that's the process that most people
use now again that might not be true of
something that is like this small and
something that is
um has a route involved that is true
yeah truly don't know but uh it's only
worth what it produces that's for sure
it's not worth what you paid for the
machines it's an unless they're worth
more as machines than they are for what
they produce yeah and a key component to
that that you brought out is if they're
the only workers even if they're not
paying themselves they still have to
account for
what someone would be paid to do that
job yeah
yeah
Okay so
if you look at it another way I'm just
staying on your idea keeping it I I
obviously they're not going to keep it
but you and I might but um yeah but the
uh I mean what they make per hour for
their labor is incredible yeah I mean
we're talking they're making 150 bucks
an hour
yeah she says it's only five hours a
week yeah so why is this killing you I
don't know that's why I had more
questions but we maybe could have gone
all day on that but it seemed like I
think there's travel involved going it's
a route right they're going from place
to place and you got all those coins
it's like a paper route only yeah back
when there were papers yeah now all this
left her pamphlets
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life and money the phone
number is
888-825-5225 Michael is in Seattle hey
Michael how are you
okay I'm good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up
yeah so
um I've done the right things uh my
whole life financially I actually
discovered you guys once I was on a
really formidable path and kind of in a
good place but being that a lot of the
the Ramsay values aligned with how I
already felt I started kind of watching
some YouTube videos whatever it's always
good to find other people that are right
I like confirmation bias as well
but uh so like long story short I'm in a
position now where I I you know all the
big purchases are done and settled down
and I kind of want to treat myself to a
second car a sports car and it just
feels
um a little wasteful just for the fact
that I know that I could do better
things uh with my money like just even
leave it in you know an online savings
account right now at four and a half
percent and you know that's still
ticking up right so it just feels a
little wasteful trying to figure out
what's the cost all the time
uh the car would be like 80 after it's
all said and done what's your net worth
uh about 1.35 okay what's your income
uh last year it was about 440. okay get
the car
get the cart treat yourself
that's kind of how I feel yes come on
now
okay let me tell you what let me tell
you the thing that Sharon and I do okay
okay because it was hard for us
to after for so many years being Frugal
for so many years it was hard for us to
make the transition to enjoy money
okay yeah and there's two things that
have enabled us to do some things that
feel in in air quotes wasteful uh but
really what that means is I'm enjoying
some money uh I've lived like no one
else so now I can live and give like no
one else there's two things that do that
number one I look at my generosity
and uh if I were buying an 80 000 car I
know that in addition to our tithe to
our local church we give
way more than that so if I were buying
an 80 000 car my generosity to wonderful
Ministries and to help the poor and to
help whoever in different ways whatever
struggling group it is that we're trying
to help
um is way in excess of our enjoyment
okay so that's one thing in other words
am I am I spending more on me than I am
on others
okay that's one that's one thing that
gives me peace about it and I'm not okay
the second thing that gives me peace
about it and this is probably even more
important is I call it the uh burn it in
the middle of the floor test
if you put eighty thousand dollars in
the middle of the floor and you set fire
to it
would your life change
no no
yeah so it passes the Burnet in the
middle of the floor test
if you put 800 000 in the middle of
floor and burned it you would oh yeah
that your life would change yeah so you
can't do that so there isn't right you
know that that that's where we are or if
you have a hundred thousand dollars to
your name and you're going to take
eighty thousand dollars and burn it well
it changes your life right
yeah so you don't pass that you don't
burn the past the burn it in the middle
of floor test and I never really named
it I never really gave it a name until
just now but that's I like that that's
there that's that I just named the test
today but um but the point is am I doing
something that tells me on I always look
at ratios and the ratio of this car to
your net worth and your income is small
enough that Jade without thinking said
right and so and that's that past the
past the the the ratio is so small that
you're not doing something dumb yeah
when you reach a point that it is
impacting your life for a luxury item or
your lug or your generosity is smaller
than your luxury item then that doesn't
pass the test yeah so you have earned
the right you need to do this and as
long as our ratios are there and we do
this uh uh um uh Michael in addition we
do this with our income because you make
a fabulous income so this is a a formula
we use uh I just got one of my uh Total
Money Makeover royalty checks this week
okay I get them I get them like four
times a year I get them quarterly and uh
so that's like mailbox money right so
any money like that above what we need
to live I just take that and I apply a
formula to it uh number one the
government gets 40 number two uh my tie
this ten percent so that's 50. that's 50
of it's gone the other 50 I split among
three categories enjoyment additional
generosity beyond the tithe and
investment additional investment and so
that check is already spent
there's a percentage that's going to go
to enjoyment without guilt
because I'm doing the additional
generosity and because I'm being
responsible with the investing and oh
I'm paying my taxes there's that but
yeah but you see what I'm doing so the
that same formula or that same
philosophy is applied in that formula do
you feel it
yeah absolutely and I mean I I think you
know the transition to learning how to
enjoy is tough for people who have been
Frugal
it's a new muscle positive Association
yeah you get such a positive association
with always saving money but anytime you
go to spend it feels really weird and
kind of foreign
that's a normal malady of somebody
that's got two million dollars it's the
first thing and you know the first time
I moved from a junk car after bankruptcy
into a decent car I went through this
like this is so dumb because these
things go down in value this is so
irresponsible
and I was buying a five-year-old Jaguar
it wasn't like I was buying some super
expensive car at the time but my
emotions were just you know fingernails
down a chalkboard because I'm not going
I'm not going to be broke again I'm not
going to be stupid again I'm not going
to get back there
all this stuff in your head you know and
so uh but yeah that that's kind of when
I had to get okay if I turn this car up
am I yeah it doesn't matter oh so I'm
not spending that much really okay I can
afford to do this I can afford this
upgrade and you can do that with a lot
of things
um and it'll keep you from doing too
much luxury stuff but um
that's so good I I also think it's
better money spent that we don't do a
ton of extravagant travel and I mean a
trip is lighted on fire once it's gone
it's gone you're no longer in the
destination you no longer have the money
and so I always felt like the car too
although it you know depreciates but if
you take good care of it and don't drive
it a whole ton if you know if your goals
and aspirations or your desires change
in a few years you can probably get out
of it with you know not too too much
damage but you won't even need to get
out of it hey I got a 1960 Corvette
because I was being born in 1960 frame
up restoration it was and I drive it
about eight times a year I promise you
if I told my wife we're doing that
instead of a trip I would not own that
car
Mission won't work at Ramsey house I'm
just saying because Sharon Sharon's bags
are packed to go on a trip I'm just all
the time so yeah but both both fall in
the enjoyment category both are okay
yeah but they're a small percentage of
your world that's right that's where you
keep it and then you don't have any
reason to feel guilty and that helps you
to hit the enjoyment button buy the car
we didn't even ask it what it was it
doesn't matter
a Porsche 911 was it he told he told the
phone screener oh definitely get that
car this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today
Jade has taught Financial Peace
University many many many times I don't
know how many times you let a class oh
okay I was going to guess higher than
that okay and you are doing a budgeting
webinar using the every dollar app on
August 9th next week right yes that is
correct around lunchtime and it's uh not
only how to do a budget the basics but
also how in important nuanced stuff like
The Irregular income like if you if you
don't have a predictable income how do
you do a budget only every dollar app
and how do you do it properly Jade's
going to teach you it's completely free
yes
completely free this is what you need so
many look I know who I'm talking to
right now it's the folks who've been
hanging out around our stuff Dave and
won't do it and they haven't done it yet
you're listening to the show you peruse
the website and you think oh you know
when the time is right I'll do it this
is the time listen if you want
entertainment watch Netflix okay if you
want to change your life we'll Entertain
You well yeah while making you get the
energy while making you not only be
entertained but making you do this
freaking stuff so yeah you listen if you
if you want to aim at nothing you'll hit
it every time yep
a budget is people telling their money
what to do instead of wondering where it
went
Zig Ziglar John Maxwell quotes right
there okay so first webinar Jade is
doing is next week it is 100 free no
salesman will call other than Jake
that's going to be doing the every
dollar showing you how to do an
irregular income and if you want to sign
up for the webinar go to everydollar.com
budgeting everydollar.com budgeting if
you don't know every dollar is the best
budgeting app in the world
millions and millions of downloads of
this app okay and it's called every
dollar because the basics of a budget is
giving every dollar a name every month
before the month begins giving every
dollar an assignment every dollar a
mission before the month begins it's
harder to do if you have an irregular
income but it's not impossible if you
have an unpredictable income and it can
be done and Jade can help you do it look
the last webinar we did actually two
webinars back because we're doing this
regularly I had a single mom come on she
had several kids and we walked through
what she needed to do she needed to
trade in her car for a less expensive
car she needed to move houses she needed
to get her income up don't she know she
came on this last webinar just a couple
of months later and she had done all
those things completely cut miosha
completely changed her life around went
from making her income she more than
doubled her income Dave wow this is what
you can do when you get around the right
community of people in a webinar like
this with a tool like every dollar
that's all I'm saying everydollar.com
budgeting sign up it's going to be
August the 9th will be the webinar
obviously webinars have limited spacing
because the technology does not allow
unlimited visitation so you need to get
over there get signed up and again zero
cost everydollar.com budgeting Jade's
budgeting every dollar
webinar August the 9th Laurie is in
Minnesota hey Laurie welcome to the
Ramsey Show
what's up
Noah even know where to start I just
know that I'm frustrated and I have um
some credit card debt that you know I I
come to find out I went and visited a
bank yesterday 27 interest is actually
kind of uh I guess normal right now but
I was livid because I used to before a
divorce I used to you know get like the
zero to three to seven percent because I
had pretty good credit and then I got a
divorce and things just kind of hit the
fan and I'm sorry so it's just been a
struggle um how long have you been
divorced
well a long time uh seven 17 years now
almost well it's probably more like 16.
well then the credit card is not the
fault of the divorce okay you got to
blame somebody else okay yeah no one
blame me yeah I'm I'm definitely all
right how can we help though it was
Necessities you know like a lot of it
you know some of it was travel you know
giving my son experiences but again I
totally take accountability that was
kind of stupid but I didn't realize it
was going to get me in the prisoner of
death that I am you know how much credit
card debt do you have hon 27 000 at 27
interest look at that okay
so how can we best help you do you think
I read your book
just from my teaching job I carry three
jobs well four with my coaching so
um summertime I do two jobs and um you
know after just the teaching just the
teaching salary during the school year
um I I make about three thousand and my
base bills come to 23.88 and that
doesn't even include gas groceries
um
you know like some of the medical copays
you know well you said you had four jobs
what do you what do you make combined
um well I think I make about well I
think I make about 60 for teaching about
six to eight for the driving driver's ed
was about two this year and coaching
three thousand so it's it's spread out
throughout the year it's not month right
it's not monthly okay right 60 for
teaching it's not 3 000 take off
that's wrong uh after union dues and
medical and
um I'm contributing 50 a month for um
and I was gonna try to take that out
because you say to not invest if you
still have debt I think right and so I
was going to take that out and I'm like
well it's only 51 yeah
um the union news are huge and then we
have tra which comes out and that's like
360 a month what is that
tra is like
um teacher retirement Association you
can't get out of that mandatory yeah
mandatory right right okay and your
union days are ridiculous too right uh
well yep every other er every paycheck
there's 60 bucks yeah sheesh thanks to
the teachers union okay
solute
um
and I tried the every dollar
still what was your tax refund
um
I paid in
okay so 600 something but that's because
I screwed up I had to take I I not
screwed up I intentionally
um reduced my or increased my exemption
so I could make it through Christmas and
then through a couple things during the
year and so that was my own Focus I knew
I was going to have to pay in so usually
it's about a thousand
do you have kids
I do one one what age
17. okay
um you're gonna have to get your income
up
that's all it is a hard job in there all
right well here's the thing and here's
what I want you to look for instead of
something seasonal I want you to look
for something that you're bringing in a
steady amount of money each month
because that's gonna that's gonna give
you a world of peace right now because
like you said having you know if your
expenses are coming to 2 800 and you got
you're only earning three thousand that
margin is too too slow you're not going
to be able to pay anything off that way
and you're going to be frustrated
exactly right but how do you leave
teaching I mean you know well I'm not
necessarily saying that you have to
leave teaching if you choose to do that
that's fine but either way you're gonna
have to get another gig that's pulling
in more money whether it's oh tutoring
tutoring yeah something you're doing on
the side yeah but again for clarity I
want you to look for something not
driver's ed in the fall and not coaching
volleyball in the spring I want you
that's good but I want you to do
something that you're getting money week
to week steadily so that you can
continue to make steady efforts
toward this debt yeah yeah and even if
it's three years to get out do the debt
free stream oh heck yeah yeah look okay
that's worth it yeah and I'm thinking
driver's ed and coach and volleyball
does not pay as much as tutoring no am I
wrong
um no right you're correct I mean yeah
and yeah you might trade that in for
something else I do do after school
tutoring as well so when volleyball's
done I do do after school tutoring what
do you get how much are you getting for
that uh it's about 30 an hour right now
yeah what I usually hear is 30 to 15
hours what people are getting these days
right right yeah that I think I'd
concentrate and double down on that
let's grow a real tutoring business
right right okay and and use that to get
rid of the twenty seven thousand dollars
because if you can make two thousand
dollars a month doing that
the credit card's gone in a year yeah
right yeah okay and that starts to get
you in there so that that's to Jade's
point so what we're always looking at
Laura is what we call the shovel to Hole
ratio how big a hole have you got versus
how big is your shovel your shovel is
your income your hole is your amount of
debt and so what Jade saw was you had a
fairly small hole but a tiny little
shovel and so all we're trying to do is
get the shovel up that's the whole thing
this is the Ramsay show
oh
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America all month
long we're giving away cash you could
win one of our 500 weekly prizes or the
grand prize of three thousand dollars to
increase your chances enter daily at
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway you can also get our
best-selling books like The Total Money
Makeover from paycheck to purpose John
deloney's number one bestseller own your
past change your future for as low as 12
dollars that's a deal you can pre-order
Dr John deloney's brand new book
building a non-anxious life comes out
October 2nd but if you pre-order it for
twenty dollars right now you get 75
dollars in free bonus items wow on top
of the 20 book there you go so all
questions for human cards conversations
cards are on sale right now twelve
dollars as well go to
ramseysolutions.com store that's
ramseysolutions.com
slash store Jade warshaw is with me this
hour the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Lynn is
in Los Angeles hi Lynn welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
I am I'm 59
um on the 10th I'll be 59 and a half and
I have a tsp that has a little over 200
000 in it plus an IRA that has I mean a
rock that has 10 000 in it and about
five in my savings I want I want to pay
off like my car and a few other small
bills and I'm wondering if this is the
time for me to take out from my tsp or
should I wait what's the total debt
the total debt on my car is 21
000 and I have uh personal loan for 7
000 and credit card probably about 1500.
okay so 30k and in order to get that
you're going to need to pull out 45.
so you're gonna have 150k left
mm-hmm
okay
then if you go borrow again
you kind of screwed this up didn't you
right so part of this formula is never
again
next time you want a car
you pay cash for it or you don't buy it
okay next time you want a dot dot dot
whatever the crud you spent this money
on
you because you keep doing this you're
gonna have no tsp left right
right so the problem is pay all this off
with no pain without feeling the pain of
the stupid decisions that got you here
and then you go back because you don't
change your habits this would be really
bad advice if you are if you can raise
your right hand and swear to yourself
I'm never doing this again then it does
make sense is this logical
hey Lynn why can't we just keep working
and pay off this debt
we can do that as well um I retired in
2020 from the post office okay but I I
am now a part-time preschool teacher
okay
um so but I I'm also a caregiver for my
dad okay my work schedule is kind of you
know we wonky depending on his health
are you married
yes what's your husband Mike
my husband is on temporary disability so
he brings in about 2 500 a month and
what is his nest egg
he doesn't have one okay so this is your
whole household's nest egg
correct
and he keeps wanting me to pull it out
and put it in the bank no but no I I
know that that's good this is that yeah
don't do that don't do that one
um
what's uh what's your mortgage
I don't have a mortgage we rent and our
rent is 1800 a month okay
I want to buy a home
but I don't think I'm in a position
right now to do that to myself yeah okay
well I think the two of you combining
your efforts and you as you're able to
not to Jade's Point go back to earning
an income uh and the more substantial
income better because
um uh
yes you're debt free when we do this but
debt free is supposed to lead you then
to the ability to build wealth and if
you don't take all these payments you
used to pay
by getting rid of the debt and any and a
good income and you use it to build
wealth and good Investments if I thought
you could double or triple Your Nest Egg
by the time you're 70
uh because you got rid of this debt I'd
be a whole lot more excited about it
that's what I'm thinking about for your
sake
does he see what I'm doing
yes so getting out of debt is one thing
but getting out of debt so that it's so
that so that I can be more generous so
that I can uh invest more so that I've
got more freedom that there's a the the
debt for the debt free part is just a is
is just a it's a an exit ramp we take to
get off and go do something better yeah
I'm wondering and I might be wrong I
feel like she retired a little too early
or are you are you required to go out at
a certain point when you work for a
government job no you're not not the
post office but anyway but yeah but it's
too late there she's gone so she can't
go back I just I but I would look at
what I can do for my second career yeah
because you're young you got a lot of
time left and
um I I would you know she's got a
caretaking with her father issue and her
husband's on disability so I don't know
what all is going on there but but I'm
gonna uh do some things to really and
preschool doesn't sound
preschool teacher doesn't sound
um like a high-paying job to me I could
be wrong well she's part-time doing it
too so I wonder if there's there is
there is something that she can do to
earn more money there's always and there
certainly is over the next three or four
or five years that's right yeah so let's
just keep that going and try to figure
out what we can do there so good
question Zachary's with us in uh
Minnesota hi Zachary welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um so uh about a year ago I was very
financially illiterate and I have a
question about a car loan at a very high
interest rate
so it is uh 15.4 I over 11 11 and a half
thousand dollars left on it I've uh
completed reading your Total Money
Makeover book and I've started the baby
steps and this is my only actual debt
and I'm wondering if it's worth holding
on to and just aggressively attacking it
or should I just sell it by a car with
the equity that I have in it and then
have no payments and start there what's
it worth
it is worth estimated private it's it's
16 to 18 000 what do you make
uh I work at the post office and I make
last year my gross taxable income I was
62 000
or yeah yeah 62 000. I'm on Pace to do a
little bit better this year and I'm
supposed to get a raise a decent raise
in uh November what lucrative side job
could you pick up and knock this thing
out before Christmas currently I am
doing in my off time I work about 15
hours a week at the post office and then
um I've been doing some instacart and
then some door dashing uh and that's
brought me up to I don't know I've only
done it for like two weeks now I think
I'm at like five hundred dollars roughly
off of that I think so you pay the car
off by Christmas
that's that's the goal and I I thought
that it'd be worth holding on to because
it's got really low miles and but it's a
terrible interest rate yeah it's a
terrible interest rate yeah that's why
you're going to have to go fast as
Lightning to pay this off and I mean
honestly you could go either way if you
wanted to you sell it and get some cash
and go to a cash car but I would just
probably keep it and pay it off I agree
I agree I would keep it and pay it off
it's because it's a small enough amount
you can do it fast enough with your
income and with your side hustle and
just bust it man just bust it and turn
turn the thermostat down and you know
turn the grocery bill down turn
everything down at home no life no
eating out no partying all work no play
get rid of the mess right
right sir I do have a two-year-old and
that is my number one priority and I've
been trying to like navigate around I am
cutting my budget up um I'm not well you
have to feed the two-year-old
but you can work like a maniac for a
short period of time to get rid of the
problem that's right that's the why
right there yeah that's it hey man
thanks for the call this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey this is the Ramsay show hey guys
if you like what you're hearing we could
use your help subscribe to the show
click the follow button leave a
five-star review
uh share hit the share button or tell
someone where you're listening or click
a link and copy it and send it to
somebody say hey check this out uh all
of those things help pretty dramatically
we appreciate it uh this week we hit
number 12 on Apple and which means out
of about 4 million podcasts that are
done in the world we are number 12. and
you guys are the reason thank you we
appreciate that very very much and that
helps a bunch because when you pull up
podcasts and the first line of six the
next line is six we're right there makes
a difference on new people learning
about us and finding us it's a big deal
thank you thank you thank you we
appreciate you and um we know this is
free and so that's what we're going to
charge you you got to help us thanks
[Laughter]
Christina what's up
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help um yeah I have a
question so my husband and I have been
working towards paying down our debt the
last four or five years and uh have
about 69 000 remaining in student loans
um and we're just contemplating the idea
of selling our home
um so and there's a lot of nuances there
um but how much debt have you paid so
far
so we have paid 37 000 to my private um
student loan so that is gone uh we paid
15 000 plus to credit card about 20 000
to the vehicles
um
yeah and then there's been a lot of both
of those vehicles have had significant
maintenance so seventy thousand dollars
in three years
yeah four four years yeah
what is your household income
um so now we both just gotten actually
new positions so I will be starting on
Monday actually at 1 40 and my husband
is right around 70. what were you all
making before
uh when I started
program I mean like during this four
years it took you to pay 70 which is
pretty lame
what were y'all making then
okay that's a little better okay all
right I won't be so tough on you then
okay so the good news is listen you
doubled your income yes yeah way to go
rock star way to go
so just don't spend any of it and pay
off all the debt this year
yes
why do you want to sell your house
well
loan and probably get about 420 or so
for it
um
and so we also know with vehicles that
both of them are a little bit older one
for sure will you know we're working on
training Christina why you want to sell
your house
I don't I really don't okay then don't
sell it but that just the just having
this no you just doubled your income one
year you're debt free
one year you increased a hundred
thousand dollars in income and you may
you only have 69 000 in student loan
debt left right
correct yeah okay and then after that
you can buy whatever car you want to buy
with cash
okay you have an extra 100 Grand that
you didn't have before
yes unless I did the math wrong did I do
it wrong
well it doesn't feel that way because
it's been Progressive I don't care how
it feels it's math yeah
um I mean you you made one ten before
and now you're making 210. that's an
extra 100 Grand right
yes okay and so why would you not be if
if making 110 you were able to pay off
70 in four years making 210 you ought to
be able to pay off 70 in one year
yeah it's illogical
yeah what's wrong and why why are you
not believing me I think you're I think
you're tired I think
you're tired and you're like man this is
what's happening and tell me if I'm
wrong but you're looking ahead and
you're going man another year of putting
all of our income onto this debt and
then after that we're gonna have to save
for his car and then after that we're
gonna have to save from Mike am I right
yeah yeah it's hard to it's hard to
because our income with us before too
it's hard to like Envision being able to
obtaining cash for those bigger so we
have six in our family my mom also lives
with us because she has some medical
issues the last couple of years and so
we need bigger vehicles and we both need
a vehicle even though I work remotely
because we have lots of appointments I
think what you're doing is you're still
seeing it through the the goggles of
your old income and it's like oh
everything has taken forever but like
Dave said you got a hundred grand more
things are going to go at Double the
speed that
that's right you got new goggles girl
put on those 210 000 goggles and start
looking at this equation and you're
gonna see that you're gonna move so much
quicker
and it's not going to be the slog that
you think it's going to be yeah so
Christina I um
in a few years back I quit but I ran a
bunch of half marathons I've run like 20
half marathons there's 13 miles okay and
somewhere around mile nine
every time I run it I question my sanity
my body is tired and my mind is tired
the nutrition the Water Runs Out the
energy the excitement the blood sugar
runs out and it and you just have to
freaking finish the race yeah
it doesn't matter what song plays on the
podcast there's nothing in your ears
there's nobody cheering on the side you
just want to hit them get out of the way
shut up leave me alone you turn into a
grouch for the last the last section of
it and you're in that last section and
the good news is there is a yellow tape
around the corner and you're going to
run through it and there's a Finish Line
and this will be done I'm proud of you
you've done better than you feel like
you've done Dominic is in Delaware hi
Dominic how are you
hey Dave how are you great man how can
we help
great uh thanks for having me on um so
basically for the past year I've been
living uh with my girlfriend at her
mom's house
um we've been working you know our both
of our salary jobs and then an extra job
on the side
um saving as much as we can and now
we've gotten to the point where I think
we have enough to kind of you know buy
our first home oh no no no no no no no
don't do that
no no never buy a house for someone
you're not married to
I'll go under any circumstances you're
about to get yourself in a huge mess
yeah you complicate the breakup like
nothing like nobody's business you're
gonna buy a house with her you better
put a ring on it first buddy I know
that's right yeah that's kind of that's
kind of the first thing right now
because we've been we've been together
for about six years now come on painter
get off the ladder I know that's right
Beyonce taught us better than that
I don't because if we get married right
now you know that's you know a lot of
money that we got to spend on the
wedding and they're buying a house
I know you're already sleeping together
wait a second hold on hold on you're in
her mother's house you're talking about
buying a house but you're concerned
about buying a ring
is using a lot of money on the wedding
and all that you don't have to use a lot
of money on the wedding Dominic please
don't buy a house for someone you're not
married to really I've been doing this
30 years and I've heard unbelievable
horror stories because you now have a
partner you have no protection under the
law this is relationally backwards it's
a legally dumb and it's financially
stupid
and everybody thinks it's all okay
because if we're going to play house we
ought to have a house to play house
listen to get married and then buy the
house I don't care if you have to put
off buying the house a little bit
because you bought too expensive a
wedding I don't care if you have an
inexpensive wedding and go by the house
anyway but do this in the right order
please I don't want your marriage doomed
and I don't want your finances doomed
and doing this out of order is it's just
suicide man don't do it please if he's
truly concerned about the price of the
wedding get married at the courthouse
and do a party later after you got your
house like it doesn't have to be all
that
yeah just do it write legally yeah
you're just going to get you just it's
you can't get out of the house there's
no I mean when you go through a divorce
the judge tells you what you have to do
yeah when your girlfriend leaves and you
got the whole mortgage and her name's
still on it and you can't find her to
get the Deeds signed because she got
remarried somewhere or got married to
somebody else somewhere and now we're
trying to get rid of the house it's a
dead gum nightmare don't do that people
get yourself in a mess this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we're so glad you're here open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Liz is in Boston hi Liz welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um yeah so I'm calling
um with sort of it's two questions that
kind of go into one so
um I'm getting four thousand dollars
back on our tax returns
and I'm gonna pay off a credit card with
that and I have another credit card that
I do need to pay off but I also have a
small business and I was wondering what
your thoughts are on putting that money
toward um as an investment into my small
business
um I have a food blog so I was thinking
of doing a website audit to see if I
could increase my website traffic
um you know to make more money off of
ads and things like that and um to go
along with that question I am a
stay-at-home mom and I guess I'm just
wondering if um I guess I'm just
wondering if I'm doing the right thing
being a stay-at-home mom
um I left my job as a physical therapy
assistant
um three years ago and I have two
children under the age of two
um I work 10 hours a week
um actually from my website host and
then once we bought on the side and I
just wasn't sure if I'm doing the right
thing okay what do you make on the 10
hours a week
35 an hour okay so 350 bucks okay and
then what are you making on the food
block
not a lot
um I it comes out to some months it'll
be about 400 because I do food
photography for that on the side and
then
um some months it's you know close to
like 50. okay no you do not put four
thousand dollars into that
okay take you forever to get it back
yeah you're not making enough to justify
a four thousand dollar investment you're
making enough to justify a 400
investment yeah yeah it would be
too much
I'm also gonna
poke a larger beer here you said you're
a stay-at-home mom I'm assuming you're
married
yes what's he make
um this year it'll end up being about 2
. so what's the problem yeah I think I
know what the problem is because you're
saying these are your your tax return
your credit cards you guys don't have
your money combined
no we don't
um we do in a sense that
um he pays all of the bills and I pay my
student loans and my credit cards
um yeah so you're not combined
all right
no
we do have it we do have a joint account
um you're not combined dear
I know what you're saying I know you
want it to sound better than what it is
but you're not combined but I hear from
your voice that maybe you would like to
be
yeah
um
I think it would be a little less
stressful
um
yeah so let me uh here's the thing
this man
has a wife
and two babies
his job is not to make his wife pay her
student loans so she can take care of
the two children that he sired
that's bullcrap
all right so the two of you should put
all of your money in a pile and the two
of you should take care of the two of
you for sickness and sickness and in
health for richer for poorer and the old
wedding vows back in the day the old
book of common prayer writing vows say
unto thee all my worldly Goods I pledge
you're good enough to have babies with
but not good enough to have your student
loans taken care of bull crap
yeah you took him if he gets sick you're
gonna make him chicken soup
and you got student loans so we have two
children we have student loans we made
the decision for you to be a
stay-at-home mom because that's what you
wanted to do and you're fretting over
eighteen hundred dollars and fifteen
hundred dollars while your husband makes
a quarter of a million dollars a year
have you brought this up to him before
that it would be a lot less stressful if
you guys could just combine your money
um
it's it has been a conversation it was
never like really
um stressed like I never really
um okay I tried to make it like a big
Point
um
I guess I feel guilty he has no debt and
I have like no he's married you
you you come with all of you you married
him
he doesn't he didn't walk around feeling
guilty about being selfish no he didn't
need to walk around feeling guilty about
dadgum student loans I'm not gonna look
I'm not gonna I'm catching a Vibe here
that I don't like at all and
Dave is right that's all because I don't
want to jump to any conclusions I'm
catching a Vibe I don't like I don't
like that you have all this guilt
surrounding a simple request I don't
like that you are feeling so much
apprehension about having this
conversation with this man that you're
married to and have three kids with so
there's a lot going on here
um
yeah if you're not going on if you're
good enough to have babies with you're
good enough to combine finances with
yeah yeah okay I mean I think he would
be open to it
um good that would speak highly of him
I would think better of him than I do I
would too I would too I think I think
you guys are just plowing along and
hadn't stopped and looked at this maybe
so let's stop and look at it because
here's the thing you're fretting over
stuff that you guys wanted to try to
check pay these loans off I'm guessing
you got the money in the bank and you
ought to clear them up it's not up to
you to do it by yourself any more than
it's up to you to feed the children by
yourself or it's up to you to uh do
everything by yourself it's not up to
him to do everything by himself okay so
we we are a team that's what we said
when we went to the altar we are a team
we are a team we are a team we both have
a vote and we both bring strengths and
we both bring weaknesses to the team we
are a team we are a team we are a team
and let me just tell you the people that
build the highest quality marriages with
the highest probability of extreme
Prosperity meaning Building Wealth and
becoming baby steps millionaires all the
data points to they work together and
they combine their finances well I want
to be independent well you shouldn't
have gotten married because when you get
married by definition you are not
independent anymore you don't have to
lose your personal identity right and
and this is not some kind of 1950s thing
I'm talking about here I'm giving you
fresh data from the marketplace that
says folks you need to combine your
finances if you're willing to combine
your bed it's not any more than that I
mean in terms of being married okay so
it's time it's time you know babies
together you can pay off Finance so you
can pay off student loans together this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
you know
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need help
getting your home ready for spring go to
neighborly.com to find Reliable local
businesses like air serve window Genie
the ground skies and more visit
neighborly.com today and find home
experts available near you all right
today's question comes from Leo in
Washington he says I'm 83 years old and
I want to know how to set up my
inheritance for my children and
grandchildren I don't want to give them
the money
that is scribbled away
I want to get I don't want to give them
money that okay I see what he's saying
he doesn't want them to get this money
and just blow it blow it yeah
um there's a couple of details I wish
were here obviously uh you're gonna
either need a will or an estate plan or
a combination of of both depending
um
if you've got you know a net worth over
millions of dollars and it's a lot of
money then you're probably going to want
something like an estate plan to really
put everything in there and decide over
time what happens to it
um if it's just a couple of possessions
and a little bit of money he might be
okay with just a will
um but there's probably more to it that
you're going to want to walk through
you're going to want to make sure that
you know there's a power of attorney set
up for your medical stuff for your
financial stuff you're really going to
want to walk through that estate
planning uh situation you know Dave
if you're just a guy you know you you
got a couple hundred thousand dollars
you've got a couple possessions is it
worth going through the process of doing
an estate planner would you just say
yeah I would go to mama bear legal forms
and do a will yeah yeah in terms of how
to decide whether you're going number
one we need to start with the premise
that just because someone is kin to you
does not mean they're entitled to an
inheritance
okay so I'll give you an extreme example
one of your grandkids is doing heroin
if you leave them money you will kill
them
because they will they will use it to
overdose
right so we do not you do not they're
not automatically entitled to money just
because they're in your lineage uh and
so you have a responsibility to them and
to God to manage this money well and so
we're going to leave it to people who
are going to handle money well and are
handling their life well because when
you get more money whoever you are me
included you become more of what you
already are if you're a jerk and you get
money you become a colossal jerk if
you're a drug addict and you get money
you die of an overdose if you have an
anger problem and you get money you're a
rageaholic you're a well-financed butt
and so you know and so on right and so
if you if you're sloppy with money and
you get money it doesn't suddenly make
you not sloppy with money it makes you
sloppier that's right so
you're not blessing someone who has uh
behavior problems and we'll call them by
giving them money as a matter of fact
you are blessing them by not financing
that yeah and have that conversation
have those conversations open and in the
in open don't make it like some big
secret of so I'm gonna sit down with a
grandkids yeah and if you want to put
them all in a pile that's fine if you
want to do it one time that's fine and
go listen those of you that handle money
well will be getting money those of you
that don't handle money well will be
getting a salute I love you but I am not
a matter of fact I love you so much I'm
not going to finance your misbehavior
and so Grandpa's watching it's that
simple hey say you've got okay say your
kids are fine and you want to split up
this money and this other thing you
can't be mad if everybody doesn't get
the same amount no but go ahead and tell
them let me just tell you fair is where
the tilt-a Whirl and the cotton candy is
[Laughter]
there is no fair okay even Jesus didn't
split it evenly check the parable of the
challenge true that Parable the talents
who got more money
the one who managed it well Parable the
talent let's read it
so this is biblical so I'm you know I'm
looking at my grandkids and go don't be
mad at me God said it okay so yeah
here's and no I'm kidding but I'll take
the blame because here's the thing I am
not going to finance your misbehavior I
love you too much to be an enabler
enablers are weak people Pleasers and
I'm not one so this is I talk to my kids
now yeah I mean as weird as it sounds we
do an estate planning meeting once a
year where all the family is there and
the leadership team at Ramsey is there
and we talk about what happens this year
if Dave dies as a matter of fact that
meeting is today was it today it is
going to be later today I'm dreading it
it's the Monty Python meeting are you
feeling just fine I'm feeling much
better it's just a flesh wound we're
planting my death all the time right so
yeah but but this has been for years I
mean the starting point of our thing is
as for me and my house we're going to
serve the Lord
and if you want to if you're gonna do
that then you're then you're gonna get
financed to do that through the the
blessings that God has given us but I am
going to make sure if you're misbehaving
that God's money is not financing it and
dad's money is not financing it because
both of you love both of us love you too
much to finance your misbehavior and
encourage your misbehavior and the
misbehavior can simply be laziness I
don't I don't I don't like to work much
not financing that why because it's not
good for you it's not sustainable yeah
right it's not it's not good it's not it
doesn't bring joy in your life industry
and diligence brings joy in your life
creating things and accomplishing things
brings joy to your life sitting around
and being really good at an at a game on
the television does not bring joy to
your life I know you think it does but
you're just numbing your mind it's a
brain candy yeah so I mean you've got to
do something with your life and so
Grandpa that's a fair thing to do and so
it's a fair thing to leave you know if
you want to leave a I'm Gonna Leave You
five thousand dollars and all that is as
I say I love you okay but uh but your
sister gets a hundred thousand dollars
because your sister's actually got a
brain and is using it yeah you know
tactically tactical question okay
Grandpa's passing away he's leaving the
grandchildren Thirty forty thousand
dollars each in the will does he need uh
that money effectively would go to to
them immediately if it were will
if they're minors I would leave it in a
truck yeah so that was that was the
Tactical part if the grandchildren are
not miners then I would just leave it to
them yeah I think that's the Tactical
part that people Miss if you've got
minors involved whether it's your own
children or grandchildren that trust
lets you decide when they get the money
as opposed to happening right if you
want if you want to keep somebody from
getting it until they're 30 or something
like that you need a trust too but I you
know again it depends on the amounts and
how complicated and how complex you want
to get into this yeah but let's start
with the premise of two things number
one no one is entitled to money
you know so I've I've met uh people who
felt like their parents or their
grandparents owed them yeah their
inheritance or that they were entitled
to that inheritance and you're just not
that's not ethically morally legally
spiritually correct it's just wrong okay
yeah number two so you don't you're not
required to leave money to someone so
get off the shame train okay now the the
second thing is is you need to really
understand with all money transactions
you are not helping people when you give
people that are misbehaving money you
are financing a larger portion of that
misbehavior oh 100 100 of the time
you're magnifying so your people don't
get you know it's like marriages don't
get bet you know where our marriage is
struggling so we had a kid well that was
a dumb butt idea that doesn't help your
marriage yeah okay it just means you're
not sleeping that's all that means so I
mean gosh and you might have to consider
your kid's spouse
do you consider the spouse as well yeah
absolutely absolutely
so if I have if one of my kids has an
overbearing spouse that is is going to
inflict values that I don't believe upon
thy wealth that I leave that I'm not
leaving it yeah
oh and you got to tell you got to let
them know that we talk about it all the
time we'll be talking about it tonight I
mean we do we review this every year we
go through it another you know we go
through this is what's going to happen
with this that's what's going to happen
with that this is where it's going this
is what we're doing and you know and
everybody gets an opportunity to have
their feelings hurt every year you know
I mean you know so I can't imagine
there's any drama in that room no there
really isn't that's what I'm saying I
can't imagine it really is and it's
really kind of boring yeah but yeah but
but at least we review it and it's
that's an act of diligence it's an act
of Love on my part so Sharon says this
is what's happening that's what's
happening to Sharon no she's taken care
of kids know how they're getting Ramsey
they know how they're going to run
Ramsey this year if something happens to
me the milk truck hits me well you know
that the proverbial milk truck a poor
milk truck driver no I if that milk
truck comes for you I'm coming for it
Dave nothing's taking you out there we
go now now I feel better feeling now I'm
feeling better you're on my side Jade
Jade's got me that's it beware ye milk
truck drivers this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today Jack is
in Charleston South Carolina hey Jack
what's up
hey there I got a question for you I
recently graduated college about a year
ago congrats what's your degree in
mechanical engineering good good for you
um and I have been working I've got a
decent job and I've got about a hundred
thousand dollars in student loans I
haven't made any payments because I've
been waiting to see if our president was
going to do anything with our loans
which he I don't think is going to
happen
so you figured that out did you yeah
what did you find the interest rate has
been deferred but
um my 100 000 is actually made up of two
separate loans one is 25 000 about the
other one is 75 000.
um my cash in the bank right now is
about 25 26 Grand and I've been
wondering if I should just outright kill
this smaller loan
um and just get it off my plate because
I've also been looking at saving up for
a house um but don't pay them on a home
and I just don't know the best way to
attack this
um these two separate loans what do you
make
um right now 86 good for you thank you
so how familiar how long have you been a
listener are you pretty familiar with
the way we teach yes yes if I had to
guess what you're all going to say it's
going to be I really need to attack
these loans
um but I just don't know if y'all would
say an aggressive aggressive payment
plan each month um and try to take them
out over the course the next five years
or just do it right now let me help you
that's what we always say Okay a hundred
percent of the time and there's several
reasons for that the probability that
you actually get out of debt
is so much higher
the more aggressive you are
and because it shortens the time and
because it's an all-in commitment
it's an emotional thing as much as it is
a mathematical thing
does that make sense yes sir it does and
so there it's weird because the thing
kind of works on a curve I mean you're
familiar you you do this uh it's like on
one end of the curve uh you're going to
be in debt forever because the energy is
very low in the middle of the curve you
don't get much of any movement you don't
get movement equal to the a equal to the
effort and on the hour end of the curve
you get movement that is unequal in a
good way to the effort because the
effort is so there's so much focus of
energy
and so because personal finance is more
Behavior than it is uh it's more
emotions and behavior than it is actual
math especially in a situation like
yours because you're going to only owe
75 000 when you get off this call and
you make 86 and last year you didn't
make anything because you're a college
student
right so you don't have any reason to be
spending 86 you could you could probably
almost knock this out in a year that's
what I think yes I know I'm extremely
low rent at the moment as well so I I
think so what you're saying in summary
is to to completely kill this this
smaller loan changed years in a highly
aggressive payment plan to knock out the
75. that's right keep yourself a
thousand bucks aside like you plan to do
and yeah highly aggressive payment plan
I agree with Dave I think you could
knock this out in a year if you wanted
to pick up some work on the side or on
the weekends maybe you could do that I'm
not sure you know how taxing this new
job is or if you're feeling you know
like let me just
chill for a second I just got this job
but so what are you 24
yes sir yeah so we're talking about 25
years old you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year you don't have
payment in the world do you know how
fast you're gonna be a millionaire doing
that about eight years
yes sir that'd be awesome that's the
plan do you see how that works while
your contemporaries are all sitting
around going
Biden is going to save me
oh no he's not
yeah and I you know I I I knew that was
going to happen
um which which is fine
um I was just waiting to see you know
what the interest rates were going to do
uh you know actually I feel like I need
to mention this one little thing too the
smaller one has got a much lower
interest rate than a larger one that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you're
gonna go so fast it's not going to
matter it's going to be calm by the end
of the day it doesn't matter okay and
and just there's the psychological part
when you just immediately get rid of one
and it's gone for good
that's that's some momentum right there
that's the moment you have some positive
momentum going we're getting some
Physics going on here so well done sir
well done hey the student loan thing is
starting uh there is everybody talks
about how bad it is and everybody talks
about how sad it is and everybody talks
about how upset people are and all this
and yet there's a whole other side of
this that yeah there's a lot of positive
things going on especially in our world
on our YouTube page that's right we're
getting comments from people who paid
off their student loan debts I wanted to
read a few of them yeah so this is on
our YouTube where we've already talked
about student loans there's enough nay
series these are the people who actually
did something about it this person says
hey I paid off 72 000 worth of student
loan debt in seven years it's one of the
best feelings I'm now working to pay off
my mortgage
I took Dave's advice back in 2020 when
the payment pause started I paid off my
loans by the end of that year it took a
few sacrifices but it was definitely
worth it wow this person says I don't
regret going to college and earning my
degrees I do regret not understanding
what I was getting myself into when I
signed for the loans I lived off some of
the money I took a graduated payment
plan when I finished school I did that
too making it impossible for me to pay
down the loans uh pay the loans down the
first five years of college I did the
same thing I didn't fully understand how
the debt was controlling our finances
eventually we refinanced the loans
privately before the pandemic sold off a
ton of assets along with working
overtime to pay the loans down we paid
them in full summer 2021 it's insane the
sense of relief that you feel not being
strapped down by debt yes I feel that
boom this guy says had over 80 000 in
student loans which was part of a
hundred thousand dollars in consumer
debt paid in full in 2019 after three
years of grinding built a dream house in
2020 put down 20 percent now on track to
pay the house off by 2025 wow getting
out of debt is a mindset more than
anything we're continuing to document
the Journey on YouTube I love that last
one she says as of two days ago I'm 100
debt free the last things to go with my
student loans and it's no more the sense
of relief is amazing a sense of relief
sense of relief it came up to it three
times yeah yes that feeling that you get
you know what and it's not
I don't want to correct them because
it's their words and their experience
but it's really not a sense of relief
it's just relief it's relief there's a
reason you have a sense of relief it's
because you have relief it's actual
relief yes because it's actually there
there's a sense of a sense of not being
weighed down why because you're not
weighed down there's you know there's
why that sense is there so yeah that's
that's interesting phrasing yeah but
yeah check out the Ramsey student loan
hub for tips and tools and the fastest
way to pay off your student loans
ramseysolutions.com student loans Jade's
got a lot of help over there you don't
want to miss out on it she can help you
and listen we want you guys to get these
student loans cleared up as fast as you
can if you haven't gotten them cleared
by October when they start back we
certainly want you to be prepared for
when they start back because it's it's
coming people and uh it isn't like we
hadn't told you for two years this is
what's going to happen so we've told you
and told you and told you and told you
and told you and it turns out we're
right and that's the bad news the good
news is we're going to help you yeah and
show you you what to do give you the
motivation the inspiration and the
information to get this done
ramseysolutions.com student loans what
all is on that site Jade so on that site
I go through three steps with you of
what you can literally today the first
one is getting organized about your
student loans because maybe it got sold
somewhere maybe you're not sure what
your payment is or what you owe I'll
help you through that the second step is
for you to understand your payment
because there's a lot of payment plans
out there should I do the save plan
should I do one of these income driven
plans I'm going to walk you through all
the all of that so you know what to do
and then finally you gotta get on a
budget guys you need a budget so that
you can actually see where your money's
going do you have the margin to pay it
if you don't how are we going to get it
I'm going to walk you through all of
those three steps it's full of resources
trust me on this I'm talking about this
Dave because I did it it's free yeah
this isn't like you made this up in a
vacuum how much student loan debt did
you all pay off 280 000 Dave yeah and as
a part of 400 and something thousand
that's right that's right seven years to
do the whole thing that's right but uh
and so you know you're sitting here with
eighty thousand dollars of student loan
debt well Jade's got your beat I promise
you and she's proof it can happen it's
proof it can be done this can be done
you are not a victim it is time to be a
Victor you need to happen two things
instead of things happening to you
Dr Stephen Covey said in the book The
Seven Habits of Highly Effective People
the number one habit
proactive people happen two things not
things happening to them you are not a
victim you're a victim of your own
thinking and Jade can help you with this
that's what we're here for this is the
Ramsay show
all right
[Music]
our scripture of the day habakkuk 2 3
patience is not the same as indifference
patients conveys the idea of someone who
is tremendously strong and able to
withstand all assaults
Thomas Jefferson said never spend your
money before you have it
it's kind of like don't go in debt I
like it loving it Jeremy's in Cincinnati
hi Jeremy welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave Jade uh glad to be on the show
well honored to have you how can we help
yeah so I I guess the basic uh point of
my question and I know I know you guys
usually would shoot this down pretty
quickly but it's basically can my wife
and I are on baby step four five and six
and I wanted to know if we could kind of
skip baby steps four and five and just
hit six with everything we got
um and so a little bit of background we
didn't really have much of a baby step
two
um we are only 25 who goes just turned
25 the last couple months
um last fall we bought our first house
and uh found out we were pregnant
shortly after and uh we just had our
first baby boy in um in April of this
year congratulations so a lot going on
thank you very much yeah no it
definitely was worse than we anticipated
but it's been a good time so
um so yeah so we have a combined income
of about 120 000 and our mortgage is
about 195. and we were considering
um I'm an accountant by trade and so I I
run the numbers like crazy uh much to my
wife's you know a pleasure how you uh no
and uh and I was like figuring out that
we could if we just focused on the house
we could be not even 29 and have a paid
for home and then um being as young as
we are that we could catch up on
investing pretty quickly and still as
high with Millions uh even if we just
did 15 at that point
okay
to show your question is what should you
do that or what yeah it would be okay to
kind of focus on that house first get it
out of the way have have more income to
well in fact you're a grown up if
anything you do is okay you get to make
your choices that's right
um sure would I do that no I wouldn't do
that would I tell you to do that no I
wouldn't tell you to do that because I
think that
um you're not going to end up with as
much going your way as you will going
our way and that's my reasoning see the
the thing you did not run your number in
your numbers was increased in income
the chances of you having zero increase
in income between 9 30 0.
and you did not run any increase in
income in your numbers you ran very
naive basic primitive numbers
did am I right sure yeah yeah so you're
if you put 15 away
um you're probably going to pay off the
house in about the same period of time
okay fair enough and then you're gonna
have a paid for house and have gotten
your other stuff going so the con and
what you're leaving out is the
opportunity cost on the money that's
what Financial people call it and that
is the the money that you put in between
now and 30. what that money will become
over the next 30 Years is astronomical
and you're missing out on every bit of
that so
uh those uh semi-balanced approach of 15
of your income going into retirement at
maybe step four now we've got a baby put
50 bucks a month or whatever aside let's
get something started on College and
we're touching the bases and then just
throw everything including all new
raises uh within reason let your wife
have a new whatever don't be an
accountant but um but yeah but but sure
but throw everything at the house and
you're still going to have this house
paid off and probably about the time you
thought you were going to anyway and
because now I'm factoring in increases
in income and um I I think you're going
to be there I mean you can do either one
Jeremy neither one of these your plan
versus our plan is not a recipe for
bankruptcy right it's not like the
dumbest thing I ever heard on the planet
or something like that you got a house
paid for by the time you're 30. I'm
loving it okay I think it's a great plan
I just think ours is probably slightly
going to come out ahead Dave I I hear I
hear here I gotta be devil's advocate
for a minute because I hear a question
from the peanut gallery okay and the
question is what is the peanut gallery
saying the peanut gallery is saying well
Dave so it's it's okay for me to miss
out on opportunity costs when I pause my
investing to pay off my debt for five
years but it's not okay for me to
pause my investing when I want to pay
off my house for five years okay well
let's also be very clear almost never
does it take five years to pay off the
debt true that you and Sam are highly
unusual yes that's your usual amount of
debt the uh the vast majority in the 90
percentile of our listeners that follow
our stuff with focused intensity with
gazelle intensity are debt free not
counting their house in 18 to 24 months
and so that is a different period of
time for opportunity costs than he's 20
something yeah and he's going to be 30
and so that's six years not two years
that's true so there's a difference
there so and um yeah and I'm not talking
about uh
I'm also clearing up uh cash flow here
that's right that that is going to
offset it well we can't learn of cash
following the mortgage too so peanut
gallery would have that part you could
clear up more depending on the type of
debt you have
on the front end
what your dad is I don't know how much
it is yeah he said they didn't have much
of a baby step too no they didn't so in
their case they're what he's
experiencing the weight of the mortgage
payment emotionally yeah which because
he's an accountant so it's very good so
that's that's cool that's that's
excellent Because by the way the number
two category of people who become
millionaires are accountants number
one's engineer number three is teacher
yeah because they're aware of they're
aware of what's going on yeah compound
interest and uh spreadsheets are uh
their second language you know and so he
just his brain works my brain works like
that so that's how I've had to fight
against my own nerd self at times that's
why I know you've thought it all through
every Corridor that this can be thought
through well I mean I started you know I
I mean like the debt snowball obviously
is not mathematically correct sure it's
a behavior-based tool not a math page
tool the the problem is it actually
works and the other one doesn't work
that's right the Avalanche or whatever
the crap people call that that's just
bull it doesn't work it doesn't work
because people people don't play all the
way through with it at snowball they
play all the way through so all that
matters is when you're done who ended up
paying off the most debt the fastest
that's what matters and it's not a
theory it's who's going to actually do
it yeah and so that then that starts to
mess with my math nerd self because my
math nerd self would say the Avalanche
works better yes
never stop compound interest never do
anything to stop compound interest
because it's it's the eighth wonder of
the world Albert Einstein said so you
know I mean you don't ever do anything
like that but uh so you have to have
this
there's more to it than math yeah
there's a well are the apparent math
sometimes the math that's on the surface
is not all the math
um
you know uh well yeah you know like for
instance I'm gonna borrow money on my
home at six percent and I'm going to
invest it in this in a good growth stock
mutual fund at 10 to 12 and I'm going to
make the spread well that's that's that
math is not accurate because you're left
out risk and you left out taxes yeah and
so when you adjust 10 to 12 for risk and
taxes it looks a lot like six
and so you didn't really make anything
on your little plan here uh and you see
these Tick Tock characters it's like I'm
going to teach my 14 year old to
Arbitrage
um maybe you ought to spell it first
yeah and maybe I'll actually understand
that Arbitrage involves risk and
leverage equals risk and uh it 100 of
the time it equals risk more leverage
equals more risk so that's a math thing
where we lift out parts of math in his
case he didn't leave out any math he's
really thinking this through well yeah
the only piece of math he left out was
increasing income that's right yeah uh
but but
um and so he's truthfully if he goes
hangs up and goes they're crazy I'm
gonna go do my thing he'll be fine he's
gonna be he's still gonna be willing
it's just a matter of you know when he's
40 if we ran this all the way out which
one of us would end up with the most
money you know and I'm promising you
your way we would we would because I've
done the case studies for 30 years I
know so it's not it's not a I think so
that that's just fun it's fun to talk
about though it is and here's the good
news about somebody like Jeremy paying a
24 inch paying attention I know that's
right it's not a zombie that's right
he's not bearing into the streets going
I vote wrong I hope someone takes care
of me you know he's not he's not a
zombie he's actually doing he's actually
paying attention that's right and he
knows and he's thinking and wise Beyond
his year if you pay attention you're
going to be okay that's right you're
ahead of everybody else good stuff Jade
good show today it's fun
oh Austin Ben James Zack and Andrew in
the booth great job the booth dudes they
did it again I'm Dave Ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]